kylie is with us in Utah hi Kylie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks Dave
how can I help so I am 24 I graduated a
couple years ago I work full time and I
owe my parents about fifteen thousand
five hundred dollars for a musical
instrument and my husband is getting
ready to go to grad school for a
doctorate program in about a year and a
half and I'm wondering do we pay them
back or pay off the the rest of the
habitated about half already paid off
their line of credit and poured like you
know keep saving to fund my husband's
program were creatures that he'll get it
all paid for talking to other students
in that same program but we also saved
using every dollar at 16,000 plus or a
thousand dollars mention people on so
I'm just kind of not sure where to go
next okay well the first rule of getting
out of debt is to not add more so so we
have to ensure that your husband's going
to school without you adding more debt
yeah beyond that beyond once you've once
you've got that assurance either from
cash or he's gotten his scholarships or
his fellowships or whatever it is he's
looking for and if that happens and you
clear this money then you don't need
this money for him to go to school then
you would use it to pay your parents off
did you say there's a line of credit
that your parents used to buy this
musical instrument yeah they did a line
of credit on their classmate pay about a
half of it off they have or you have
they have okay so you still owe them
fifteen thousand five hundred but they
only have a seven thousand dollar line
yeah I just hate the ideas I'm having
monthly payments that are because of me
yeah yeah so you bought a fifteen
thousand dollar what thing
say it again a balloon a bassoon okay
yeah I played professionally and on an
international broadcast and my school's
all paid for so it was really not an
amazing choice Belgium had some benefit
yeah and so you're using that now to
make money
yes and so what is your income my income
and is about forty thousand meter okay
and your husband is working while he's
going to work on his graduate level work
yep he works at allowed on campus about
part-time okay so your household incomes
what fifty something like that I get
Commission and Chris sale so it I'm
looking around 55 usually you you get
Commission's on sales yeah I Anna played
professionally and I also work for a
non-profit where I feel advertising and
memberships for organization oh I say so
how much do you make playing
professionally not as much as I make the
nonprofit I need to couple hundred
dollars a month okay alright and so what
is he studying metallurgical engineering
okay hold on yeah yeah so you guys are
right brain left brain couple okay all
right so well I I yeah I think I want to
get your mom and dad paid off as fast as
possible but if the net result of that
is you borrow money for your husband's
education you really just moved the
money you just move the debt around so I
don't want to do that I want you to have
figured out in your budgeting and the
cash that you have available and the
benefits that he gets lined up that he's
going to school without any additional
debt and then any money that's left
after that can go to your mom and dad
okay that's what I would do
okay interesting story huh took me a
minute to get to the bottom of it but
thank you thank you
very cool